♪ ♪
>> Greg: JOE BIDEN HAS ONLY
BEEN IN THE RACE FOR ONE WEEK
AND HE'S HAVING HIS PRESENCE
FELT ACROSS AMERICA.
IT'S LIKE HE'S HUGGING THE
NATION AND READING ON ON OUR
NEXT.
SURVEYED BY TOTAL JOBS FOUND
3 OUT OF 4 PEOPLE ALL WANT ALL
PHYSICAL CONTACT BAND AT WORK.
OF COINCIDENCE, I SAY NO.
IT'S NOW TOO HARD TO FIGURE OUT
EXACTLY WHAT IS APPROPRIATE.
SOME COMPANIES WANT TO BAN
HANDSHAKES.
SO NO MORE PHYSICAL CONTACT
ALTOGETHER.
LEAVING IT ALL UP TO THE PEOPLE
AT H.R. WHO CAN ANNOY YOU
WITHOUT TOUCHING YOU.
I AM 100% BEHIND IT.
MAKE THAT 99%.
BANNING ALL TOUCHING INCLUDING
HANDSHAKES MEANS NO ONE WILL
EVER BE ABLE TO SAY YOU MADE
THEM FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE.
THAT'S GOOD AS SOMEONE IN
MANAGEMENT WANTS TO FIRE YOU.
NOT TOUCHING ANYONE REDUCES THE
SPREAD OF VIRUSES, ESPECIALLY
WHEN ED HENRY IS AROUND.
THE CONS, WE CAN NO LONGER TELL
WHO THE WEIRDO IS IF THE WEIRDO
CAN BE REARED IN PUBLIC AND
THAT'S HOW I CHOOSE MY FRIENDS.
I AVOIDED THE GUY WHO LIKES TO
SHAKE YOUR HAND AND REFUSES TO
LET GO WELL HE TALKS.
IT'S LIKE A MUTT WHO WON'T GIVE
UP A BALL.
I AVOID THE LADY WHO CARESSES MY
BACK WHILE SHOWING A CAT CARTOON
FROM THE NEW YORKER.
IT'S THE CARTOON THAT REALLY
BUGS ME.
HOW DO I KNOW WHO'S WEIRD IF
THEY ARE BANNED FROM BEING
WEIRD?
MAYBE THEY WILL GET A SHOW ON
CNN.
THAT'S USUALLY A BIG HINT.
I WROTE THAT SO I COULD SLAM
CNN.
JESSE, YOU SHAKE A LOT OF HANDS,
DON'T YOU?
OR DO YOU FIST BUMP?
SEEMS LIKE YOU WOULD.
>> Jesse: I DO BOTH.
HOW ARE YOU SUPPOSED TO SEAL THE
DEAL IF YOU CAN'T SHAKE HANDS?
HANDSHAKE DEALS.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS IN BUSINESS
ALL THE TIME.
YOU ALSO SPOT WEIRDOS BY HOW
THEY DRESS.
THAT'S USUALLY HOW I SPOT THEM.
>> Dana: WHAT IS A TELL?
>> Jesse: IF THEY DRESS LIKE
GREG.
>> Greg: WHAT'S WRONG?
>> Jesse: YOU HAVE YOUR GENES
ROLLED UP.
>> Greg: YOU ARE HEIGHT-IST.
LIFE IS SO GOOD THAT WE HAVE TO
FOCUS ON HANDSHAKES.
>> Juan: I DISAGREE WITH 75%
WHO SAY WE SHOULD BAN IT BECAUSE
IT'S A CULTURAL NORM.
YOU SHAKE HANDS.
YOU MEET SOMEBODY.
HELLO.
IN EUROPE, THEY KISS EACH OTHER
ON THE CHEEK.
MY SISTER LIKES TO DO TWO OR
THREE HOW MANY TIMES ARE WE
KISSING?
IN JAPAN.
>> Dana: WE SHOULD START THAT.
START WITH ME.
>> Greg: I HAD TO BRING OBAMA
IN FOR THE HECK OF IT.
DANA, I SENSE THAT YOU LIKE YOUR
OWN PERSONAL SPACE.
>> Dana: I AM A HUGGER.
>> Greg: YOU NEVER HUGGED ME.
>> Dana: I DID ONCE.
>> Greg: IS IT MY ODOR?
IT'S A BIOLOGICAL PROBLEM.
>> Dana: THE ROBOTS WILL BE
HERE SOON ENOUGH.
WE DON'T NEED TO BEAT THEM TO
IT.
WE ARE MEANT TO TOUCH.
>> Greg: I CAN DO THE SOFT
HANDSHAKE.
>> Jesse: FISH HAND.
>> Greg: WHEN YOU GET A SOFT
HANDSHAKE, IT CREEPS YOU OUT,
JEDEDIAH.
>> Dana: THERE IS A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE I KNOW IN
THE RACE WHO HAS A WEAK
HANDSHAKE.
IT'S NOT A WOMAN.
>> Jesse: DO TELL.
IS IT MARIANNE WILLIAMSON?
[LAUGHTER]
I DON'T KNOW WHO THAT IS.
>> Greg: JEDEDIAH, WHAT IS
HAPPENING TO THIS WORLD?
THERE IS CRAZY CRAP GOING ON
EVERYWHERE AND WE ARE FOCUSING
ON HANDSHAKES.
>> Jedediah: I AM A
GERMAPHOBE.
THE IDEA OF HANDSHAKE --
>> Greg: IT'S IRONIC.
>> Jedediah: I AM A HOWARD
STERN STYLE GERMAPHOBE.
HE WOULDN'T TOUCH ANYONE.
I ALMOST FEEL LIKE A HUG IS LESS
INVASIVE.